let's go to our caller from the 7:04
area code who's calling today from 704
hey is that me yeah hey David
um I'm very sympathetic to the argument
that you provide on behalf of litem
the reason I can't personally bring
myself to voting for him is because he
seems to me to be very just physically
mentally fatigued there are moments
during his campaigns debates interviews
rallies whatever it might be or is he
seems kind of confused and I was
wondering you just feel that it's better
to have some kind of trap that here
people mentioned the possibility of a
democratic draft so your opinion beyond
that I think it's insanely unlikely that
that would have you mean like drafting
some other candidate yeah like of all
places the National Review just put out
a publication about drafting Cuomo
yeah I finally feel about home oh yeah
honestly he would probably be a better
pick cuz I don't know fighting can
exactly compete against Trump it could
be any center-left candidate
it's just Biden doesn't seem to be
mentally and physically up to the task
yeah listen unbalanced if you said to me
in a vacuum would I prefer Cuomo or
Biden I probably go with Cuomo for a few
different reasons the thing about you
know the Biden dementia stuff and the
physical health stuff I mean Trump's an
incredibly obese 73 year old who clearly
seems to be suffering from cognitive
decline as well so if we even if we
grant that this is like some kind of
dementia race which I don't actually
think from from the things I've read is
the case but even if we grant that I'd
still rather it be Biden because if
something happens to Trump it Spence if
something happens to Biden it'll be
somebody much better than pence or Trump
so so it's I actually think that we I I
don't have the power to say we're
replacing Biden with somebody else all I
have the power to do is to evaluate
which of these two people do I prefer
even granting the worst possible
dementia theory that anybody has I still
prefer Biden over Trump I mean that's
that's the that's the a reality call it
an unfortunate
one or not but that's the reality right
well that's my one saving grace in terms
of fighting being candidate that he has
like a very solid VP candidate just in
case it's just one of those things where
you know Trump is worse than Biden in
many ways it's just that in terms of
like competitive debate if those two
going at it side to side it seems like
Biden would just be just slower and he
wouldn't necessarily be able to keep up
with a lot of the you know pettier
insults that Trump would levy Adam I can
see I can see here's the only thing I'll
say in advance of the Bernie Biden
debate you had a lot of people sort of
counting on hoping for and expecting
Biden to implode so violently and
embarrassingly that the primary would
instantly flip to Bernie Sanders and it
didn't happen it was just sort of like a
pretty uneventful debate in in most
cases I also think that people expect
being this brutal implosion between
Biden and Trump probably also will be
underwhelmed now that doesn't mean
Biden's gonna crush these debates I'm
not saying that but if you're counting
on this implosion that people were also
counting on in the Bernie debate I
probably wouldn't hold my breath for
that yeah well I hope you're right then
anyway love the show man and things
taking my call all right thank you
appreciate hearing from you very very
much that will do it for calls today we
are going to go to a break sorry I
wasn't able to get to everyone but we
did hear from from some great great
people we will take calls again and I
will hear from you next time